ce ne sont pas dans les élections que le
sort des opprimés peu avancé nous avons
décidé d'occuper la direction nationale
de l'indh prix 1 aucun salarié de
chercher la moindre en fait avancé
social a été le fruit d'un rapport de
force si philippe barde vous préférez
qu'on pense
[Musique]
violence là où je vois la violence c'est
dans la fermeture de choses des milliers
de familles ouvrières qui vont être
plongés dans la misère qu'ils font
très déterminés prêts à rester
l'opposition hmm hmm je vais vous dire
ça me fait rêver ça ils s'invitent à
pôle emploi il s'invite sur les plateaux
de télé il s'invite sur les
champs-elysées et moi je le pense que
oui tous ceux qui sont opprimés et bien
ils doivent inviter sans quoi n'existe
pas en fait on est même invisible
[Musique]